modern airliners are incredibly safe for
every 3.1 million flights was only one
accident in 2015 136 people did die in
accidents you have to put that in the
context of 3.5 billion passenger
journeys but if the worst does happen
rest assured that no matter what the
emergency your pilot is ready and is
practiced for this moment over and over
again
pilots typically have to put in eight
hours every nine months in a simulator
like this one which can cost 18 million
dollars each
today we're going to fly one as we walk
in I can already see that this is very
realistic this is an Airbus a330 200
simulator that's a wide-body jet that
can carry over 300 passengers thankfully
they're not simulated to virtually judge
me from the outside these things may
look like a Star Wars 80 80 with a nice
fresh coat of white paint but inside
they're nearly indistinguishable from
the real thing even the view is
convincing until you see a change from
day to night all right so we can
simulate just about any kind of weather
and George if you could make it snow of
course definitely the sorts of
conditions that I would like my pilots
to have practiced we have certain
takeoff weather minimums and a Boston
here we'd probably have to at least see
500 feet we could demonstrate what
that's like you want to put the RvR to
500 and show you this is all we would
need to legally take off six actuators
provide a full range of motion and the
forces inside really do feel real you
tilt the front up and suddenly you feel
like you're barreling down a runway and
into the air it's fun sure but it's
their ability to simulate emergencies
that's invaluable
say an engine fire
and I want two of us again alright I'm
canceling a lorry
we have an engine one fire indications
which one is that which it alright so
engine one is this control this set of
engines thrust lever number one we would
pull that back to idle following the
steps idle engine master one off okay so
once things are stable we're going to or
actually I'm going to try to land this
flight back at Boston on just one engine
that's not the plane insulting me that's
the automatic safety systems trying to
keep us on course my hands are clammy
I'm sweating it's so easy to get wrapped
up in the idea that a whole plane is
depending on me to get this right
weather on the way down and that was
still a very gentle landing I don't
think I would have even sport my drunk
and then of course you turn around and
realized the whole experience was
simulated and hey that's the whole idea